給你們看我做完了家庭版毛孔深層清潔之後的皮膚狀態
就連上那些凸起的顆粒都沒用了
皮膚看起來非常的平滑
毛孔都感覺細膩而且是自彈水光感的
這個家庭版深層清潔的方法我
22年的時候第一次跟家想出然後他就爆了
那今年是第五年了
我每年都會更新一次
今天是5.0版本
5.0的版本
他是增加了補兆原的部分
也就是黑老和家庫毛孔的部分
像有一些幾點清完之後
就是很擔心說
說我的毛孔會不會變大呀
完全不用擔心
那這個清潔方法
他可以說是讓我們有鬥激從滿面
爛鬥逆形成不一張鬥
連心裡光滑的最打工程
不只是說我自己有這個效果
這五年這是有無數有的
這件沒給我來飯
可以說他有多久的效果
那我現在雖然現在眼裡
不太聽原理的剪了可以直接滑的後面
他之所以這麼有效
是因為他能把我們毛孔表寸
和深層的用紙
全部都清楚來
像一般的清潔泥膜一樣
還有洗面奶泄妝用
他們都只能清潔到我們的皮膚表層
但是真正讓我們長鬥長必口的
是那些卡在我們毛孔裡面的深層油紙
像我們油皮主要讓大
我們的腳至層
他就容易堆激的非常厚
就像一個密不透風的強力
裡面的油紙
他出不來
我外面的貨幅品還要進不去
時間長就會容易
門鬥挖門必口
還會把我們的毛孔真的很大
那家庭版毛孔深層清潔裡面
他是有三道清潔步驟的
就是相當於給我們的毛孔
做了一次非常徹底的大小儲
把我們潛層和深層的油紙全部都給清出來
所以我們毛孔通暢了
我們的鬥鬥必口黑頭
自然就會變少
後續的貨品也會更好吸收
那堅持做我們就會走向一個正向循環
皮膚越來越好
那這個5.0就做完之後
你就感覺皮膚
他不只是說乾淨通透
還非常地細膩飽滿
摸起來很有彈性
那接下來我就一邊操作一邊
來跟你們分享具體的流程和原理
那第一步就是
先來打開毛孔的門
然後我們用一個黑頭水
靜濕化妝棉
服務在臉上
我們最好是在洗澡之後
抖臉的狀態做
這個時候熱震氣當為毛孔都打開了
我們總共負在我們的額頭
比意一下吧
這種粗油很多
很多液油只堆積的地方
像我的臉
連這兩些人這樣必口
我也會負在臉底下
還有這個嘴教著
這裏品的話是我目前用起來
我覺得效力最高的一個
而且它的溫和程度也好夠
因為我膚上臉
覺得很舒服
一定的不吃人氣
用它膚碗
我都不需要產那麼辛苦的
我輕輕鬆鬆就可以把那些油脂都產出來了
那這種我們配合一個
熱盤真臉十分中
這一步真的很重要
熱盤可以讓我們的油脂服出來的效率加倍
它的溫度可以讓我們毛孔口的那些表層
有這種話一部分
這樣配合我們的黑頭水
輕而一舉的
就可以深入裡面把那些藏在它
還腳腳的油脂服出來
我一般就是把這個
整理的水全部蒸完
那我們現在就可以用黑頭產開關了
這一步超級爽
現在先用酒精來打擦一下
注意我們臉上臉
你不要一次進全部拿掉了
你產也個區域你就接哪個區域
我們產黑頭的口居人就是
形擦是輕輕壓
慢點產
我們小幅度的慢慢輕力
你不需要太用力過某
然後我們就是一邊輕輕的產
一邊用一個精師的花椒臉
稍微的融化一下皮膚
我們就不怕說產紅
會產破皮
溫和油乾淨
那全部清理完之後
我們用水把臉上的殘留
充洗乾淨就行了
好的現在我產完了
那第一步
如果你覺得有些油脂
還沒有產出來
不用張紫紫
沒關係
你不要用力去對
我們還有第二步
所以我們現在能先把臉上殘留的
這個黑頭水區
用清水洗掉
那接下來我們進行第二步
就是利用水和原理
付出失存油脂
剛才我們只是說把我們毛孔
表層的門打開
但是依舊有些玩過的油脂
還在裡面
你不清楚來
過兩天皮膚就又打會原形了
變成之前的那種顆粒狀的
好
我們把臉上的
自來水擦乾淨之後
現在我們就膚上
我們的老家冰藍膜
這個麵膜不能隨便選
如果是有一些那種
很蠻膚很年齡的麵膜
你在這部膚的時候
你第二天有一包都
最好還是跟我
用一樣的這個藍膜
那我自己的額頭
彼此下方是很難清理油脂的
所以我把剛才
你個麵膜
袋子裡面的精華液
拿這個棉片
然後
在這邊
又在貼上去
加壓
讓它在水河效果
更加的明顯
我們服他個十到十五分鐘
這部就是除了
能夠給剛才
產完的皮膚
不水舒緩之外
更重要的是
利用水河
作用把毛孔身
處的一些
軟顧的腳衰
讓他們自己服務到皮膚表面來
方便我們第二次清理
這樣我們就可以做到
零食腳清淨
那服完之後
我們把這個膜不拿下來
之後不要去洗臉
我們直接拿這種
很厚實的
這種原頭的粉絲棒棒
就覺得
我們臉上
這個麵膜
滑溜溜的精華
也開始清潔了
也一定不要用那種
很薄的圓環
那種特别特别的
商皮膚商毛孔
清完臉
特别的紅
你第二天早起來臉還是紅的
這種圓形的
它就是
非常的厚實
沒有那麼商皮膚
一邊輕易邊捐用這個膜
不去擦試
讓我們的皮膚
始終保持在
一個濕熱
對這種滑溜溜的狀況
你不能拿這個
在那個臉上乾掛
乾掛的話
就很容易掛破皮
然後很容易掛很紅
比一次
我們就從上往下的
縱向掛就好
臉加和俄頭
我們就這樣子
很像的去掛
稍微的優一點
利益上皮膚微微熬線
那些油脂
髒東西就會被清清
霜霜霜的帶下來
給你們看一下
我掛出來了多少
就是這些髒東西
把我們的毛孔
都成大了
讓我們長鬥髒必口的
我們現在去用清水
把臉洗乾淨
把臉上得去隔精華
也洗掉
不過現在
摸我的臉
好平滑
看看 今天是感覺
非常非常非常非常通常
非常乾淨
整個臉現在摸起來
各個搭搭都沒有了
這個下巴上面的那種
疑慮力力的也沒有了
毛綜繳了
現在我們是第三步
用酸安洞磨
來徹底的輸通
我們前面兩次是物理的清潔
這一次我們用酸來化學清潔
但是手乾淨吧
酸洞磨圖在我們
腳這層後油脂多的地方
進行二次輸通
徹底的清潔我們的皮膚通檔
我們復的時候
就是要記得避開
全骨眼周這種腳
這層比較薄的地方
像我們剛才清完的毛孔
是中空的狀況
這個時候用酸
真的是比我們平時
用酸有用它也多太多了
一個是清潔的會更徹底
第二個是可以加速
老費角質的代謝
讓我們的皮膚更嫩
而且可以從源頭上調節
我們皮膚出油
讓我們的毛孔越來越細膩
串動磨都害我們就選
自己可以耐受的就行了
我用的是這種復合算
它就是裡面有好幾種算
所以不只是做清潔輸通
還可以幫我改善按程
它用完之後
我是會有一種皮膚
被泡了光的感覺
我第二天我的毛孔
也會成一個那種收集的狀況
我們復甩多磨的時候
還可以用一個冷福椅
編輔編幫我們震驚
剛剛清完的臉
加速退後
然後還可以利用熱帳冷縮的原理幫我們
收緊一下毛孔
這個雖然它復兩分鐘就可以了
要很高下
好的 我喜歡臉了
到這一部我們清潔的部分
就做完了
你們能隔離皮膚感受到嗎
這很張臉的毛孔
全部都在大空的呼吸
現在我們就在進行5.0升級版的第四部
補交園加過毛孔提升夫致
叫我們前面的清潔部罩
已經波拖了倒飛腳致了
毛孔也輸通了
這個時候來補交園
吸收路徑是最短的
可以直接專禁裡面去工作
阿嬤的皮膚給撐起來
這是幫助我們收縮毛孔很重要的一部
我們的毛孔他是一個洞
你要想而他變小
那就是一定要讓毛孔裡面填起來
那怎麼填就是補交園
非常簡單沒有任何負擋的手法
就是準備一個足夠清爽
並且能夠被皮膚直接吸收的
交園精華就可以了
那我用的還是這個交園胖
你們可以用這首上有的
一定要足夠的清爽
好吸收
當然就把我們剛才清過的臉
又獨出了
好 我們全臉呢
圖兩遍
特本是鼻子的
然後還有額頭吧
你哪裡毛孔出大你就在哪里多
你留一下
如果你覺得你的法令我很重
對人家這邊有文
或者這邊有文路
你可以把多圖一點
因為它也是黑老的
最後我們就點一個清爽的
胸後面上做風層就可以了
把我們的交園和營養全部都所在皮膚裡面
那我今天用的是
到底給我們好好修護一下
就是這種很水很水的
非常清爽
這樣子才不會把我們剛才清過的毛孔
又給主上
現在你圖什麼貨幅品
都會感覺超好吸收
你就感覺好像你之前貨幅鳥
那貨幅品全部都沒有圖金區域
好了 那我們的整套流程就結束了
就這樣去睡覺吧
你睡一個寶教
第二天起床就會發現
整張臉前所未有的通透之外
整個臉都會發光
目前都是那種
軟軟的淡淡的
然後看起來超級細膩